[Music]
[Applause]
uh chip kelly fourth year at ucla and uh
2-0 beat hawaii and lsu and coach joins
us on the program coach congratulations
how did you celebrate after the win
against lsu
we went home because it was a night game
so there wasn't a lot of celebration um
you got to play the late games here on
the west coast
got to get your sleep so we got to be
back in the next day and grade the film
so just went home after the game that's
it nothing
no it's game two
well okay it it feels like this was a
big win
did it feel like a big win to you
it did i think the rose bowl was
electric um you know obviously
you're playing a team from
lsu and you know the sec west and you
know the reputation that they have and
what a good football program it is so
our guys were excited about it but also
i i was sort of surprised at the
physicality of of your team against the
team from the sec we normally see it the
other way around how important was was
it to try i mean you guys pushed them
around certainly in the running game um
were you surprised yeah i mean
that's just what we are you know and you
don't know i don't think we were
surprised but i i
that's what we have to do to win you
know that's our strength um we've got a
veteran offensive line coming back we
have two really physical running backs
um so we knew going into the game for us
to
have any success on the offensive side
of the ball we're gonna have to run it
um and then our play action pass um was
really successful coming off of that um
but that that's kind of who we are you
know we're not gonna try to because we
have an opponent in here like hey let's
line up and and uh
no backs the whole game and throw the
ball over the joint you know that's not
what we do um and it's really the test
is we do what we do they do what they do
and then you see if it works and we were
fortunate to come out on top but when
did you decide that you wanted this
style of offense as opposed to what
everybody else is trying to do in
college football and that's you know
five wide and let's just fling it around
yeah you know when i left college um we
were basically five wide flinging around
and had shiny helmets and then when i
came back to college everybody had it
um so maybe just being a contrarian
let's go the other way
um but it was also a byproduct of the
players that we had here when i got here
there were a lot of tight ends um so
let's exploit them um when i was in the
nfl i had zach hurts and brent selleck
we were in 12 personnel a lot in the nfl
so i learned a lot about playing with
multiple tight ends um so um we're just
trying to play to our strengths and um
we've got a good group of those guys and
we have two tough hard-nosed physical
running backs so um
it fits us right now and i wonder about
that that would we see this like
basketball everybody shoots the three
and i wonder if somebody's gonna be
contrarian and go hey
you're gonna have to stop us inside
um you know having a running team as
opposed to everybody you know defensive
players are not as big as they once were
they're you know speed you got to cover
everybody and i wondered about that with
college football are you are you trying
to exploit that that you see an opening
here
yeah you're spot on you know a lot of
people ourselves included have put more
speed on the field on the defensive side
of the ball but if you put more speed on
the field you sacrifice some size
um so then what is the match up that
you're trying to exploit you know is it
if they're small you want to go big and
if they're big you want to go small so
um the key is having the ability to do
both you know and and whatever the
situation dictates you can do it and i
think that's what the good teams do you
know you look at
um alabama who's probably the the top
team in the country um you know last
year they they threw the heck out of the
ball with mack jones and all those
receivers but they could run the heck
out of the ball with maggie harris also
so they had if you have the ability to
do both i think that's what makes you
elite so i think that's what we're all
striving for um but good coaches
good teams they they play to their
strengths and that and obviously our
running game right now is a strength for
us do you wish you were playing this
weekend
i do i mean i wish we played every day
to be honest with you um
but obviously the nature of the game you
know it's not baseball you only get 12
opportunities we did get an early game
and that was beneficial to us um i think
you grow the most between your first
game and your second game the fact that
it was our second and their first was an
advantage for us um but because we
played a week zero game you're going to
have to get another buy in there and our
our first buy occurs this week um so
we'll use this as an improvement week
we're out the field in about an hour um
we'll get a couple training sessions in
this week and then get ready for a
really good fresno team who played
oregon really close this uh this past
weekend he's chip kelly ucla head coach
joining us dan patrick show you know
you're there in hollywood uh you know
all these actors famous people do you
get mistaken for anybody
uh jackie chan
no
i don't think i get mistaken for
anything
maybe an older vanilla ice i i know i
don't think so i don't
i don't uh okay i don't
know
thank goodness
you could be a farley brother
okay
they're funny they are i'm not as funny
as them
i could laugh i would be like the farley
brother that just laughs while the other
guys tell jokes are you funny in
practice
it depends on my mood
i can be sarcastic in practice
which is my northeast upbringing um
i think i'm funny now someone else may
not think i'm part of it
because alabama players talk about nick
saban and they say he's funny in
practice
yeah i would think it depends on
who the player is or belichick you know
belichick the players who play for him
like bill he's got a great sense of
humor
he does have a great i think that's one
of the biggest misconceptions in this
world because everybody judges bill by
his sound bites um with the media but
as a person and when you visit with bill
i mean he's one of the most
intelligent well-thought-out sharp
people i've ever met my entire life so i
can see that bill's got a great sense
you can
but does he crack you uh like how does
it work though chip when you when when
you're out at dinner or you're you know
what what yeah
what happens it's
it's just i think
people have a perception and then
there's the reality and uh
i think he's really sharp it's it's a
dry wit um and a lot of times it's
coming out of left field because there's
a could be a serious conversation going
on and you're like did he just say that
and it's uh
it's hilarious but he's really really
smart and
and it's intelligent humor it's pretty
it's pretty it's pretty funny but do you
talk can you talk football when you go
to dinner
with belichick yeah i think you can talk
football 24 7
so the conversation always goes back to
that but then it changes when
he'll tell you
about his trips and
where he's been and what he's done um
you know he's not just a football guy 24
7
but he's
he's he may be one of the world the
morals most interesting man if you get a
chance to visit and talk with him
but but he's never going to let that
happen though chip yeah that's that's
what makes it interesting
[Laughter]
uh you have no [ __ ] blue shirt on today
i see
i just heard about that uh yesterday so
um
i do a lot because those are our school
colors i guess so we do wear those
shirts a lot um that's part of
what we show up to on home games so um
i think it was just it was funny i think
uh people have had fun with it um
you get you there's a lot of banter that
goes on when you walk into stadiums i've
learned that it's better just to not say
anything
and get into the locker room but
um coach oh
coach can handle himself so i i worry
about that fan he better make sure he's
careful what he says
i wouldn't want to tackle without well
the the joke is funnier when you win so
it's it's oh yeah yeah
isn't that always the case yeah um
uh good luck thanks uh congratulations
on the win against lsu great to see you
we've come a long way since i had you on
during covet and we didn't know what the
hell was going on with college football
and
it seems like a long time ago
it does i was in a submarine for about
16 months and the only time i ever came
up from air was to talk to you guys and
uh
it's good to finally be on the submarine
and back out with fans in the stands and
um back to some sense of normalcy so
it's it's uh it's good it's good we just
got to keep this thing rolling thank you
coach great to talk to you again all
right dan take care thank you that's uh
chip kelly ucla head coach got the week
off and then they got fresno state we'll
take a break back after this